the authorities were able to hack that
message and arrested him like they
stopped his car and I think he's rotting
in jail he was taking his buddy to the
airport I think it was Dubai or
something and his buddy messaged him on
WhatsApp saying hey by the way I have a
CBD pen that I left in your car Dubai
and the United Emirates is somewhere you
do not want to get caught with I've got
another news story here American Facing
Goods in Dubai prison after cannabis
traces found in urine a man who legally
enjoyed some cannabis in his home of Las
Vegas is now facing three years in
prison in the United Arab Emirates Peter
Clark flew to Dubai on February 24th on
a business trip looking for recording
studio the retired game designer then
went to hospital following a
pancreatitis attack he was reported to
authorities when doctors found hashish
traces in his urine which is considered
possession in the UAE oh my God that is
insane